i we do have a bunch of stories
specifically addressing that in schools
but i do want to focus on this real
quick while we're talking about like
media manipulation and lies we have this
from the new york post new cnn boss
chris licht to focus on truth after slew
of scandals chris
it is honorable that you would try to
purge cnn of its trash but you will
never
you will never save that brand i'm sorry
cnn's new boss kicked off his first day
on the job by telling employees he wants
to focus the network's reporting on news
and truth amid criticism over the
scandal scarred network's heavy emphasis
on opinion-based shows chris lick to
officially replace cnn's disgrace to
boss zucker on monday uh following
stinson's executive producer at the late
show with stephen colbert and cbs this
morning circulated a memo to his
employees saying too many people have
lost trust in the news media i think we
can be a beacon in regaining that trust
by being an organization that
exemplifies the best characteristics of
journalism fearlessly speaking truth to
power challenging the status quo
questioning groupthink and educating
viewers and readers with straightforward
facts and insightful commentary while
always being respectful of differing
viewpoints first and foremost we should
and we will be advocates for the truth
you know why saying that
because the dude who now owns
the majority shareholder in warner
discovery wan said he wanted to or or
something happened where it came out it
was reported he wanted to purge
all of the opinion lefty garbage from
cnn so this guy's like i don't want to
lose my job i believe in truth as if i'm
ever going to go to cnn for truth so i
can't stand the subjectivity of truth
truth or object
truth is not an objective state people
perceive reality as objective but the
way you perceive it is your truth so
people are going to see reality in
different ways for one person to attempt
to arbitrate that is insanity here come
the ones
give me the ones give me all the ones
give me 20 of them also what would cnn
be like what does he envision cnn to be
with you know he's like it's going to be
this truth and you're going to purge all
the like in this scenario where it's all
purging all these like you know the far
like what is this going to become just
late night with yeah stephen colbert
yeah i don't know
apparently exactly how could this guy
have worked on colbert think he's going
to everyone's going to trust him he
probably did the vaccine dance yeah yeah
i know i think he did
that was that was probably him oh my god
who was it who did the fouchy thing
where they were dancing and they had the
thing that's they spread it open and
they were spinning with it and it was
like a big picture james corden was that
okay
[Laughter]
you know it's like
these shows like colbert they exemplify
that joke jeremy boring made about bezos
they're they're wealthy and powerful but
just so not cool
and it's just absolute cringe you know
seriously when when colbert for those
who didn't see it he did this thing
where he had like what was it like women
and men dressed up like syringes dancing
yeah yeah jeez and it was like that he's
so zany i can't believe he went there
who were they that really
have a couple questions though
did they do any market research
and if they did who are they targeting
are there like
there's no on my a
i can't imagine anybody in the key demo
is watching that going like i enjoyed it
colbert whoever watches it like the
people who like colbert probably were
like this is great i've always thought
he was trash like on the on the daily
show when he got his start uh as a
correspondent he was just a liar and a
fake he was doing comedy but he was
alive
he was doing a character then he got his
new show where he's playing the
republican fake guy and he tells people
he would literally he was like satire
show but he would say things that he
didn't believe as they were real and
like just screw people's minds bull crap
artist and then he's on this show like
we're supposed to all of a sudden
believe anything out of this guy he's a
trash liar for a job i mean maybe he's a
nice funny guy but i've never seen him
like dig under the surface he was great
on strangers with candy if you ever saw
that oh gosh i couldn't bring myself to
watch actually he did it didn't look
like he was pretty good in that movie
like as an actor it was a show but yeah
he's a talented actor yeah as you can
see he's playing his new show is
it's as bad as it gets i don't know i
don't trust i've never trusted him i
made a video on 06 about this about
colbert's artistry is his crap artistry
i don't i've never liked that guy and
and when jack pasobi came on here and
said that jon stewart stephen colbert
were the spearheads of the
politicization of of comedy and
basically i think that makes so much
sense mm-hmm like
no no i didn't mean no no no no no you
guys i was just gonna feel sorry okay
well i was just gonna say that i
remember writing years ago we talked
about this on the show a little while
ago actually on this episode about the
whole clown nose on clown nose off thing
that a lot of these late night hosts and
particularly jon stewart would do i
remember he got into a debate with
tucker carlson and he was grilling
tucker and tucker starts pointing out
factual inaccuracies with jon stewart's
show and his reporting and he goes
because it's a comedy show it's like oh
was that the bit was that the bit that
you were getting facts wrong on purpose
no you wanted your audience to think
that that was true the jokes were in
other parts of the program that's so
stewart is one of those guys that he'll
say something and then if you dig into
him he's like hey i'm a comedian layoff
idiot but then if you say it he's like
no you know try and throw his like
weight of being popular at you it's
really gross and it's like it's fine to
do jokes and politics right but if
you're saying something that you intend
for people to believe as true and it
turns out to be false you don't get to
fall back like oh come on man i make
jokes don't take anything i say
seriously no yeah no i don't like it
well this is the embodiment of that
obnoxious kid when you were younger
being like you know i'm just playing you
know i'm just playing i'm just joking
but if he can get away with it he will
so this is classic this
i love you danny but comedians sometimes
do this where they like to pull up the
ladder after them i don't know if you've
noticed this but these oh
[Laughter]
and i really feel like this is just like
um literally so many of my favorite
comedians all of them it's almost like
david cross used to be literally my
favorite comedian and now and he did all
the stuff where he's almost like he's
now apologizing for everything he did
and he's like everything i did that was
so funny eight years ago is you know all
cancelable stuff like the guy that took
all the psychedelics and he's like hey
don't do psychedelics yeah yeah i i had
a great time like the 90s were a great
decade but you were just water for you
you know i gotta i i've been i'm
wondering though like if this can last
so i pulled up colbert's ratings he had
a total average viewer of 2.95 million
and this was reported as of june 9th of
2021 so
last year
he was getting 2.95 million and i'm like
um that's the live plus seven race i
don't know what that means is that key
demo or something you know look at this
results
here we go adults across 25 to 54 the
late show wins with a 0.5 with 614 000
viewers against jimmy kimmel's live with
489 000 and the tonight's shows with 477
000 okay that makes sense
so
colbert beats kimmel and fallon with a
0.2 over their zero point ones i don't
know what that means and they don't give
me the i think that's like the share uh
the decimal is like oh look at this look
at this across total viewers
late night uh averaged one million
viewers over the season so is that
colbert is he late night
no that was cordons that you just
i think you said lately no look like oh
oh that's myers is late late night and
cordyn's late late show right this is so
similar to names it's such crap i know
it's so stupid but it does look like in
the key demo it is only like half a
million viewers
yeah i mean i don't know anybody who
watches these shows yeah yeah i was
going to say
those are people our age
yeah that means i mean also you get as
many
watchers as these like super highly
produced
you know insane budget shows yeah it's
just i mean margins are incredible
we're putting we're doing crazy stuff
with it i can't say exactly what we're
doing but we're doing some
infrastructure stuff right now dancing
syringes yeah that's right dude that's
such a good bit yeah come on
i i will hire 1 000 people to dress up
like syringes and pants let's go in dc
yes oh my goodness no dude that was
something the thing like the late night
show
every now and again there's some late
night stuff that that at least was
decent in the past so i thought conan
was pretty funny but like i wasn't
tuning in every night it's a weird
format because like an incredibly good
comedian can maybe churn out an hour
a year and you've you have these
comedians you have to go on stage every
night and do like 45 minutes of material
it's just even if they're good and
they're not id logs it's not going to be
good yeah that's a good point it used to
be an interview show we talked about
this last week and now the the interview
format is on youtube people make their
own they just like you know johnny depp
doesn't need to wait to get invited on
the tonight show to talk to the crowd he
can just make it a youtube video yeah
and they're promoting stuff always right
they're like hey i'm promoting my movie
and you're like why am i watching you
talk about your movie i can just watch
like
it's kind of like people would write
reviews about video games i mean people
still trying to do that you just go to
youtube and watch the gameplay footage
if i want to see if the movie's good i
just go to youtube and watch the clips i
i just had a crazy idea i think we
should do it is
to have bands
have bands yeah like these these shows
will periodically be like you know we
have a musical guest playing music or
whatever friday nights maybe like we
used to do the friday jams back in the
day we'll do a friday night show and
then we'll also have a musical guest to
perform afterwards play music and we'll
just start taking over this space i
guess it's got to be like not not family
friendly that's a big problem with these
shows is there they can't say the wrong
thing it's you can't give the middle
finger to the people during the show
like meanwhile you don't do it
i know you see but if we're going to do
like hard just hardcore roxy and bring
it back full on get [ __ ] getting
people naked on stage
like one of my job yeah
um but just yeah i'm all about it let's
bring the real back to reality well look
i i could studio audience like
i mean we could
chickens chickens as the audience
yes you bring them out we've talked
about doing friday nights at a venue and
doing it like a live thing uh i'll
explain this to people who don't know
cause i know a lot of people probably do
the reason we try not to swear is not
because we're worried about youtube or
anything it's because there are people
who listen to this on their way to work
or picking up their kids and i actually
had we got people emailing being like
hey man i love your show but like when
you guys say these things i don't want
my kids to hear that and i'm like that's
a fair point you know if we don't have
to swear we shouldn't i guess we do it's
about swearing and profanity i find some
things can be profane without the cuss
words like if you can say things that
are very graphic sexually that aren't
aren't cussing but way worse for a kid
to hear than saying the f word or like
totally agreed and action movies with
death and murder and stuff i think with
parents too they don't even care so much
about the word it's the fact that now
the kid just says it all the time and
they don't really get it and then it's
just like inconvenience you know they
just keep they hear and they go i just
say this all the time you're like you
can't say this
at the grocery store no you can't
interesting
yeah the f word has a lot of different
meanings depending on how you use it
very versatile words it's one of the
probably the most versatile i think so
yeah right adjective it's a verb thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you